hi
um so my name is natalie posted i'm head
of experimental design and reporting at
b t fiance
and in this presentation i'm going to
talk about the newly revised arrived
guidelines
and how they support transparent
reliable and reproducible animal
research
so before i start i'd just like to
introduce the organization briefly so
the nc3rs is the national center for
free arts in the uk
and we're an independent scientific
organization which is funded by the uk
government
uh we were funded relatively recently in
2004
and we lead on the discovery and
application of new technologies and
approaches
to replace reduce and refine the use of
animals in research which is
traditionally more than the
asterisks we are so partnership is key
to everything that we do
we work with scientists and
organizations across the bioscience
sectors and that includes universities
other funders the pharmaceutical
chemical and consumer product industries
and regulators so most of our budget
goes into research funding
we are the main funders of freeze
research in the uk but we also have
in-house programs of work which are led
by the scientists in the office
including a program on excellent design
and reporting
and reproducibility is a subject that
has been dominating the scientific
headlines in the last few years
and this is something that we're very
concerned about at the interference
animal research is normally justified
with a harm benefit analysis but the
likely benefits to science and society
like new scientific knowledge or
improvement in human health
are weighted against the likely harms to
the animals involved
but if studies do not yield robust
results of reliable results because for
example the underpowered because the
risk of bias
has not been addressed or if studies are
now reported in enough details
then they can't actually add to the
evidence base a new knowledge cannot be
generated and there are no benefits to
society
so such studies are waste of animals not
to mention the implications when
entire programs of work of clinical work
are based on the findings of unreliable
animal research
and for research to be reproducible it
needs to be reported fully
and the weber disability project cancer
biology is a very good example of that
so this is a project that was set up and
began in 2013
following the publication of reports
from the pharmaceutical industry
that 80 to 90 of published research
could not be reproduced
so the project has already published
replication results for 16 of the
replication studies in the journal
e-life
and the bottom line is mixed most
studies reproduce part of the original
papers
but some were also reported results that
were not consistent with original papers
and what i want to draw your attention
on
is the um the scope of the study the
initial target was to replicate 50
high impact paper and then in 2015
that target was reduced to 37 papers
in 2017 it was reduced to 29 papers
and in 2018 it was used to eight years
and that decision to cut up some of the
replication was taken because
costs and resources were spiraling out
of control
and one of the main reasons given was
that methodological data
lack elsewhere one of the main reasons
given
was that methodological details were
lacking from the original publications
and so there are not enough details in
the publication to enable
the researchers to reproduce the
experiment describes but another thing
that's frequently missing
from publication is information allowing
readers to assess
how reliable the results are likely to
be so this is a preprint which was
published a few weeks ago
and in there researchers used the
science core software to analyze 1.6
million
open access papers from permit central
so the graph on the left
specifically looked at papers recording
animal research and shows that for
papers published in 2018
the percentage of papers mentioning the
use of measures to reduce stability bias
is very low randomization to allocate to
groups was mentioned in 37 percent of
publications
blinding in 12 percent of the
publications and power capacity in seven
percent of the applications
and the graph on the right shows the
evolution of the reporting of these
measures over the last 25 years
across all papers so that also includes
clinical research
and you can see that there has been some
improvements over the years
especially for the reporting of
randomization which increased from 10
percent in 2000
to 30 last year but the reporting
prevalence of these measures is still
low
and this highlights a problem with the
reliability of animal research
and whether we can actually trust the
results that are published in the
literature
and to improve the reporting of
information in animal research
publications
we developed the raf guidelines so these
were published in 2010
they've just undergone a revision and
the updated guidelines arrive
2.0 will be released in a few weeks
the guidelines consist in a checklist of
items that have to be included in
manuscripts
to ensure a comprehensive and
transparent reporting
so all these items are important for
different reasons for internal validity
for example a description of the study
design how the animals were allocated to
groups are how the sample size was
chosen
is crucial information to understand how
reliable and robust the findings are
some of the items are important to
ensure that papers contain enough
information to repeat the studies that
are described
so for example a description of the
experimental procedures or the animal
characteristics
and we'll actually enable other
researchers to repeat
the the methods and other items provide
information about the context and the
scientific relevance of the studies so
for example
the scientific background developments
to other species or ethical approval
so these guidelines apply to all in vivo
research whether using a mammalian
species or an invertebrate
it doesn't matter the species used does
not require ethical approval because the
guidelines are about rigorous science
so that applies to any experiment
and the guidelines are endorsed by many
of the major stakeholders in scientific
research
so about a thousand journals recommend
the guidelines and then struggling for
others
and in the uk all research councils and
major biomedical research
funders were early adopters they met
reporting publications in accordance
with arrive at condition of funding
and also instrumentally getting the
universities on board
so today many funders recommend the
guidelines like the welcome trust in the
uk or the nih in the u.s
significant level of support from
universities on both sides of the
atlantic as well
for example in the u.s stanford john
hopkins recommend they use
and most universities in the uk have
released the public statements
of support and there's also grassroots
reports
from the researchers themselves so over
the past three years
we've actually had 40 000 requests for
um
printed copies of the the guidelines
from different
50 different countries
and the arrival guidelines do not only
have reporting of research
they also encourage better quality
research and this is a study which was
published by
hanover and colleagues in 2016
and they conducted a survey of all
individual researchers in switzerland
they asked detail about the conduct of
animal experiments and they specifically
asked about seven measures that are used
to reduce the risk of bias
so those are allocation consentments
blinding randomization
sample test circulation inclusion
excursion criteria
primary outcome and a predefined
statistical energy
plan so they asked researchers whether
they generally used
these measures in their own research and
whether they reported so in the latest
publication
they also asked researchers whether they
had heard about their guidance
and 50 said that they had and then they
calculated an internal validity score
for each participant based on these
seven criteria and they found that
researchers who knew about the right
guidelines scored higher
so there is an association between good
practice in experimental conduct and
reporting
and there are guidelines
and as we were preparing for the
revision of the guidelines we also
gathered evidence from
an international survey of individual
researchers so that survey had two
objectives
first to replicate the findings from the
swiss researchers
and test whether knowledge of the
arrived guidelines was associated with
more rigorous experimental conduct
and the second objective was to gather
qualitative evidence on the use of the
guidelines to inform the revision
um so in terms of um the relation
between the guidelines and
experimentation contact
um we got 356 complete service back for
this section
um and this is just about the sample
size that was needed to detect the
effects i was observed in a swiss study
with 90
power and 209 researchers i have not
heard about there are guidelines or
we're not sure
and 147 researchers were aware of the
guidelines
so we did detect a difference and we
found that knowledge of the web
guidelines is associated with more
rigorous study design
the effect size corresponds to the use
of half an extra measure to reduce the
risk of bias
the main differences were seen in the
exclusion criteria
predefined analysis plan and the sample
test calculation
and of course this is a correlation it's
not causation
but that's good news and that shows that
there might be benefits of reporting
guidelines such as arrive
beyond just improving transparency of
reporting
and in terms of reasons for not
reporting information covered in the
guidelines
in this section of the survey we asked
about 13 pieces of information that are
covered in the guidelines
and that we knew were often not well
reported or fully understood
and so we would um we tried to gather
quality
data and assess what we could do to
improve in the revision
so for example we asked whether
researchers reported measures to which
is
buyers or details about the experimental
design and crucially if they did not
report it we asked why
so this is a very high level summary
and this is also self-reported by the
authors so we know that that percentage
of responders saying they're explicitly
reporting
information are not representative of
the prevalence rate in the published
papers which is normally much lower
but what we were interested in was the
reason for not reporting this
information
so obviously it varies depending on
which arrival item
but the main reason for not reporting
was that the author did not think he was
necessary
and what this shows is that the poor
reporting is actually reflecting
um the perceptions and the attitudes of
the scientific community rather than
journal behaviour
and that gave us a lot to work with in
the revision because
if researchers don't understand all the
information they need to be reporting
or if they don't understand the
relevance of reporting it when they pick
up a copy of their
guidelines then this obviously limits
the impact of the guidelines and needs
to be addressed
so the revised guidelines will be
released in a few weeks
but an interim version was published as
a preprint
on bioarchive last year the main
departure from the original guidelines
is that we have prioritized the items in
two sets
and that's to allow a step-by-step
approach
in the implementation so the arrive
essential 10
is the minimum requirement that's the
basic minimum to include in the
manuscript because without this
information
reviewers and readers cannot completely
assess the reliability of the findings
presented
and we know that journalists don't have
capacity to check compliance with the
entire arab guidelines
so we're proposing an expert consensus
on the information to prioritize
and this promotes a harmonized approach
across journals to ensure that all
manuscripts contain essential
information that's needed to appraise
the research
we've also updated the guidelines and
added a few new items such as protocol
registration and data access which will
now uh went on a radar 10 years ago when
the original guidance came out
and we've developed an explanation and
elaboration document
and so that document explains the
rationale behind unite each item of the
guidelines
it clarifies key concepts and it also
provides
illustrative examples showing how this
information can be incorporated in
manuscript
and these are reporting guidelines but
they're also really useful for the
design
and i really recommend that you read
them before starting the study so that
you can make sure that
you are planning the study in a way that
you would be happy to report
transparently
and also to ensure that you're
collecting all the information that you
will need to include in the publication
so revising the guidelines has been an
extensive and collaborative effort
and with input from the scientific
community carefully built into the
process so this is to make sure that the
guidelines are relevant to all the
individual researchers
and the revision has been undertaken by
an international working group with
expertise from across the life science
community
including funders journal editors
statisticians methodologists and
researchers
from academia and industry we also used
a delphi exercise with excellent
stakeholders to maximize diversity in
field of expertise and geographical
location
we had 19 we had experts from 19
countries providing input
and we've also considered um
sorry i forgot to talk about the road
testing following the publication
um of the guidelines in bioarchive the
revised guidelines and the explanation
document were also what tested with
researchers preparing manuscript
describing in vivo studies
and that's to ensure that these
documents were well understood and
useful to the intended users
and we've also considered other
reporting standards
as part of the revision to ensure that
we didn't provide completing advice
which would be confusing to researchers
so arrive 2.0 are compatible with other
guidelines that have been published in
recent years
and because they provide a comprehensive
set of recommendations that are
specifically tailored to the description
of individual research
using the rav guidelines to write a
manuscript actually helps other comply
with more general reporting requirements
like the nih standards for example
so now i would like to spend some time
on um they arrive
at central 10 and i'd like to explain
why this information is important to
including the manuscripts
so the essential 10 include information
about the study design and the sample
size
but the sample size on its own doesn't
really mean anything if we don't know
the exponential units
so the sample size is the number of
explanatory units so that is the
entity that's subjected to an
intervention independently of all of the
units
so it must be possible to assign two
experimental units to different
treatment groups
and to identify the experimental units
the key question to ask is what are you
applying the treatment to
so if you're playing the treatment to
the individual animal like an injection
then it could be the individual animal
it could be the cage of animals for
example if the treatment is given in
in the food um it could be a breeding
female or a liter if the treatment was
given to a premium female
it could be part of an animal like a
limb or it could be an individual cell
or it could be an animal for a period of
time for example a crossover study when
the animal received different movement
and separated by a washout period and
sometimes there are more than one type
of experimental unit in an experiment
so it is not always straightforward to
identify the experimental units
and when reading a paper it can be
impossible to know for sure what
the number relates to so just to give
you an example this is an experimented
in fish
so we've got two tanks with ten fish per
tank
and the treatment is diluted in water so
a drug is added to one of the tanks and
the vehicle is added to the other tank
and we can making measurements on each
fish so we've got ten measurement per
tank
so in this case the experimental unit is
the tank
and we have an equal one grip because
the measurement on each feature are not
independent
and they should be averaged at the tank
level the treatment is actually given to
the tank
so being explicit about the experimental
units used is really important
because as a reader of a paper you'd
probably draw different conclusions if
you're looking at data with
n equal one per grip or an equal tempo
group
and the guidelines also insist on sample
size justification
and a lot of people are wondering why
underpart experiments are such a problem
because if the p-value is below the
significance level
then that probably means that there was
enough power to detect an effect
unfortunately it's not that simple i'm
going to try to explain why
um so the main parameters that are used
in the per calculation
are the effect size that's the minimum
difference you want the experiment to be
able to detect which is normally based
on what would be
biologically or clinically relevant then
you've got the viability which is
normally based on previous experiments
but if you cannot estimate it you can
actually there are other ways and you
could use standardized effect size for
example
um there's the power so the power is the
percentage of true positive the
experiment can detect
so normally that power is set between 80
to 90 percent
if the power is 80 that means that if
there is a true
effect to be detected and you're running
the experiments 10 times then you'll
actually detect the effects 8 out of 10
times
and then there's the significance to a
short so that's the probability of
obtaining a false positive
so if you set the special.5 which is
what it normally is
then that means that in five percent of
the cases you will get
a significant result a statistically
significant result when there's no real
difference so that's the false positive
so now let's think of a scenario
when you've got a thousand hypotheses
that need to be tested in a thousand
experiments and let's say that 10
10 of these hypotheses are true so that
means that
in that means that in a hundred of the
experiments there will be a true
difference to be detected
and in 900 of the experiments there's
actually no difference between two
groups and strong
so we're going to run these experiments
with 80 percent power
and let's see what happens so
when we run the experiment with 80
powers out of the 100 experiment where
there is a true difference to be
detected
we're going to detect 80. so we're going
to get 80
true positive and 20 false negative
then out of the 900 experiments when
there's nothing to be detected that's
the
um juts in yellow um we
are significant threshold not five so
five percent of those
are gonna come back with false positive
results so five percent of 900 is 45 so
we've got
80 true positive and 45 false positive
so now in terms of what's going to be
published in literature
because we tend to publish only positive
results
that means that 125 experiments are
going to end up published in the
literature
and out of this 36 is actually false
positive
so that's very high um but actually
this has got nothing to do with sample
size yet this is just because of the way
non-hypothesis significant testing works
and because of publication bias which is
a different problem
the issue is that most experiments most
animal experiments are actually not
powered at 80 and and this review which
was published in nature neuroscience a
few years ago
shows that the average power in
neuroscience animal models is actually
between
20 to 30 the median was 21
so let's go back to a scenario and see
what happens when we run these
experiments with 20
power instead of 80. so out of 100
experiments when there is a true defense
to be detected
the green the light green square and
we're going to detect
20 so we're going to get 20 true
positive results
and 80 false negative then out of the
900 experiment when there's nothing to
be detected
a significant threshold is not changed
it's 0.05
so 45 experiments are coming back with
false positive results
so now out of the 65 experiments they're
going to end up
with the with positive results in the
published literature
69 is now false positive
and that's really scary when you think
of it that way because that really makes
you think that you can't trust
anything that's published in literature
um the another item included in the
essential term is the inclusion and
exclusion criteria
um and those are really crucial
information to include in a paper
and scott and colleagues provide a very
good case for it in the analysis of a
common model of als
in mice so this is a model that has
shown very poor clinical translation
many treatments that were published to
work in mars do not actually show
efficacy in humans
and the researchers analyzed the
historical database of animals that have
been used as controls
in efficacy studies to investigate the
reason for the discrepancy between
results in mice and humans so the data
is quite noisy there's lots of variation
between animals
and they use computer modelling to
explore this variation
and identify what fireballs caused it
so they sampled animals at random and
assigned them to grips so by chance
they obtained differences in survival
time between the groups
even though none of the animals have
received any treatment and this graph
shows that the frequency at which group
differences were seen
depends on the sample size so the
smaller the sample size
the higher the chances of seeing
differences between the groups
so when the simulation was run with four
one microgrips the effect was detected
in 55
of the time and with 20 animal per
groups the effect was still in 25
of the time but when appropriate
exclusion criteria were applied
this frequency reduced drastically so
when they excluded animals that died
from non-airless causes
and then they also excluded animals that
did not contain enough copies of this
transgen
then at n equal 4 the frequency of
apparent effect was reduced from 55 to
35 percent
and n equals 20 it would reduce to less
than 5
so it's actually very likely that the
published study that had reported
that the treatment worked in mice
actually detecting noise rather than the
actual effect of a drug
the guidelines also insist on
randomization and the method used to
randomize
so when you allocate animal to treatment
groups the method of randomization is
really important
haphazard is not random and you need to
use a validated procedure to randomize
anyone into groups so for example
a computer-generated list of numbers
throwing a dice flipping a coin
something that you can't influence
and randomization has two main purposes
first of all it helps minimize selection
bias
and reduces systematic differences in
the characteristics of the animals that
are located two different groups
so if you used a haphazard allocation
for example
you might end up with all the slowest
mice at the just some group
randomization also helps you meet one of
the key assumptions
of the statistical analysis that says
that different groups should be drawn
from the same background population
using random sampling
so if you've not randomized animals into
groups then actually you shouldn't be
running a statistical analysis
data and this demonstrates
the difference between ab hazard and
random
so this was an internet survey a
participant was simply asked to pick a
number between 1 and 20
um and we had 347 responses
and what this graph shows is the human
responses
compared to responses that a computer
would give
and as you see on the graph the white
bars are the computer
and the white bars really oscillate
around the five percent line which makes
sense there was 20 chances so
one in 20 chances of the age number
that's five percent
and you know the computer will actually
oscillate around that
but if you look at the human responses
now it looks like the most random
numbers were seventeen and seven
seventeen was picked in nearly twenty
percent of the time and seven was
speaking over ten percent of the time
and clearly that's not random that's
because of
you know culture and psychology and you
know seven and seventeens aren't prime
number
it doesn't matter what the actual reason
is the bottom line is
humans can't do random so randomization
needs to be done with the validative
methods
that cannot be influenced by human
judgment
we can see the impact of randomization
in the published literature
so these datas are from uh michael
mcleod's group in edinburgh
and these are findings from a systematic
review which looked at the efficacy of
intervention
in in vivo module of multiple sclerosis
so they combine the results of 126
studies
looking at 36 different drugs and they
compared studies that were randomized
to study that did not mention anything
about randomization
and they found that in the studies which
mentioned randomization in the
publication
um the drug improved the symptoms by
about 20 but in studies that were not
randomized we did not mention anything
about randomization
the effect size was 40 so that means
that the effect size was actually twice
as big
in the studies that were not randomized
and in all likelihood it was completely
overestimated
blinding is also a very important um
item in the arriving term
um and i'm just going to show you this
very interesting experiment which was
carried it carried out in the 60s
by rosenthal and vogt and these
experiments involved 12 students
two different population of rats there
was a population of males bright
rights that have been read of a
meditation to perform well in their
starbursts
and a population of men's doll rats
which have been bred over many
generations to perform pulling that
viruses the assay was a simple elevating
team as with two arms
a white arm and a dark arm the dark arm
was reinforced
so during the training phases the rats
would get a food reward when they got to
the dark on
and then the essay was run for five days
um and the
the number of correct responses was
assessed
so as you can see um on the green line
the bright rats started off better than
the derats
and they actually improved further
during the course of the experiment
and the issue is that this experiment
was actually not done on the rat
it was done on the students and the rats
had been labeled
rights order randomly in the morning of
the experiment
so the only difference between those two
population of rats and the difference
that's shown on the graph
is actually in the minds and the
expectation of the investigators
the students actually reported that they
liked working with the bright whites
better they were nicer to work with they
were tamer
one student even got beaten by the dow
rats and and that's what makes that
difference in the graph like it's got
nothing to do with the rats actually
being different
as the starting point but everything to
do with the expectation of the students
towards the rats
during their experiments and the
behavior of the students to what they're
at during the experiment
and that's why blinding is so important
and we also can see the impact of
blinding in the published literature so
this
is the same systematic review that i
showed earlier on the effective drug
in animal model multiple sclerosis and
this graph here shows the difference
between
studies which reported that the
assessors were
blinded or were not aware of the
treatment allocation when assessing the
results
two studies which did not mention
anything about blinding
and again there was a difference in the
fact size so the studies which did not
mention anything about blinding reported
the 40 effect size but um the infectious
was only 30 percent in the studies that
had been blinded so
again studies that were not blinded over
estimated the treatment of fixing
um the new arrive guidelines um as i
said will be launched in a few weeks um
and then we come with a brand new
website
and so right now that the link starts on
the slide will take you to the arrive
page on the entertains website but we
are
preparing this new website dedicated to
the rav guidelines which we launched
when the guidelines are published
and as with the current website this
will include many freely available
resources
and so for example a feedable arrived
checklist so those are used to indicate
in which section of the manuscript the
relevant information can be found
and some journals request this checklist
as supplementary information so we will
make these available
for the essential 10 and and for both
sets in their guidelines so that
journals can tailor the requirements
um we also include translations the
original
guidelines are available in eight
different languages and that's
particularly helpful for organizations
in non-english speaking countries to
disseminate the coinlands to researchers
we're currently working on the
translation for arrive 2.0
and the website will also include
explanation and examples for each item
and then over the next few months we'll
add new resources
and that includes an operationalized
checklist to assess the manuscript
compliance with the essential term
so that is something that could be
really useful to editors and german
staff
and to finish um i just wanted to
mention other resources that we've
developed to support scientists
quickly so they're all available freely
from the industrial websites
um and one resource that's highly
relevant to in vivo researches
and goes hand in hand with the web
guidelines is the experimental design
assistant which is an online tool that
helps researchers design
robust in vivo experiments and provide
statistical feedback
and that's the end of my presentation so
if you want further information
you can check the rav websites um
otherwise my email address is on the
side so please feel free to send any
question by email
and i just wanted to acknowledge the the
working group who worked on the arrival
revision here on that side
okay great job so that is a wrap pretty
much from here i'll just do some quick
editing
on the front and back ends and then also
be sure
to reach out to you about the slide
timings
for slide 19 with the animations there
um and then i can send you a final
preview link for you to
take a look before the event goes live
next week
is that there's a slide when i mumbled a
little well
i can't remember which one that was are
you able to cut that out
um let me see it was towards the
beginning correct i think
yeah um let me
make actually i do remember this one
when i just forgot the point
um find it
that's slide it was on that one
slide 13 13
okay i made a note for that so i could
take a look there
awesome okay um
bullet
yes
see here and there was was there one
other slide that you mentioned
the animations weren't working correctly
so i so it's not i think the animations
were fine it just required an extra
click but i don't think that's going to
show
anywhere um okay it was that one was a
bit weird
like if you look actually on that slide
if you look at the little
the fish are fine they all look weird
and they um
so but it doesn't you know it's not a
big deal
if you can be fixed easily go for it
otherwise you can just leave it it's not
an animation anyway so it doesn't make
any difference
okay i'll make a quick note just to take
a look at
perfect okay well i will get started on
this editing
and send over a preview link as soon as
possible so you can take a look
at um what we've got recorded here
and then for slide 19 in those
animations we can get your feedback on
that and make some adjustments
there all right okay all righty um any
other
questions for me before we wrap up here
no i think that's fine that was quick
yes no timing was great as well so that
was awesome
but if any other questions do come up
please let me know if not
i will be reaching out to you shortly
okay brilliant thank you very much thank
you have a good rest of your day
and you thank you bye
you